[Music] all right Aaron pay attention because I'm
going to have you introduce the second episode
citizens of the reject Nation we are here to watch
Invincible season dose today if you didn't catch
our reactions for season one that I did with Aaron
Alexander over here they're up here on the channel
as well as our reaction to Invincible Adam Eve
special I'm excited I did a rewatch over the
past couple of weeks so that way I could remember
the name Mark Grayson everyone else's name that's
washed over my brain ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do be polite and ask Aaron how he's doing
so he feels included in the video Aaron how are
you doing I'm doing great baby killing the intros
I am killing the intro that's what I love to hear
is a compliment about me that's why I asked you a
question leave a like on this video people that
would mean the world to m w also subscribe click
the notification Bell cuz you best bet we're going
to be covering all this this is a fantastic show
thank you to prepper to help us edit down these
highlights as always full length and watch along
the three sync up with your own copy of invincible
that is avail able for our super sex rejects over
at our patreon page also we cover several
shows over there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included let's see
what season 2 is all about man I'm excited let's
[Music] go oh the wait is [Music]
over oh damn okay he really is Immortal this
guy this man cannot die I've been hit harder
before like way harder so arrogant just like
your father yeah maybe are they just training
or does he not trust Mark yeah feel like they're
training yeah he not going for any death blows or
anything yeah he has to be cuz this is the
closest thing he has to fighting someone like
his dad and they have to prepare for the uh the
Army that's coming back why can't you trou me oh
after what omn man did after what you
did oh maybe this is a dream this is a
dream kill him for the third time on me
man awesome God
damn nightmare was a nightmare The Immortal
lived for thousands of years trying to make
this planet better for all its people but did
not succeed thought he'd see the truth like
you did how there's still brains on his head
yeah we know you all feel like we're the bad
guys because my dad and I took over your
planet this a long dream you're going to
be part of the filtrum Empire now he's
torn between paths the more you resist
the worse this gets we didn't didn't destroy
your cities you destroyed them by fighting
back way to blame join us in welcoming them and
if you still think you can stop us don't forget
I'm invincible people I just plays on repeat
I don't think it's a dream maybe it's like a
Multiverse situation I was just thinking
that yeah alterate Universe kind of thing
no one dies from cancer and no one ever
messes with Earth again ooh Secret group
fighting against the enemy angstrom were
you followed the immortal LED them away
we're safe yeah that's what Rex thought too yeah
Multiverse oh that's hot did you retrieve the null
energy Sarah Conor [__] if this doesn't make
omim man have a bad day nothing will the null
energy T versy guy [Music] oh [Music] wa
it's cool that you get to see Mark go down
this dark path in this version yeah [Music]
right no he can't feel [Music] it oh wow
fascinating more destruction at a train
station someday you too will die a but
you should have died at Birth damn so
mean she looks like neas on a teenage teenage
Warhead with that the whole fit from from
Deadpool one you and your stupid resistance
made us kill thousands of innocent people you
made us you made us your fault stop this or
I stop you please I'd rather die I love the
manipulation conversation I would never kill
you but I can't let you hurt anyone else no
he's going to disable her you just lied you just
lied she didn't leave you a choice well no he
justified just paralyzed oh she's paralyzed yeah
that's better so that's what you were practicing
on those protesters last week I couldn't
figure it out so Sinister say how casual
he is about it it's just so disturbing hey buddy
you sentenced yourself to death when you joined
Club resistance justice justice will come for
you that's Sterling K Brown oh yep I hear it y
wheree Multiverse let's finish this off I'm
starving Purge I'm on I'm on team evil
amican omn man side how a goat clearly
they know what they're talking about I'd
rather be on The Winning Side why would
you not want to be come on D the blood D up
blood is still there Perma blood Mark left a
mark that a villain in the water oh
that's smart or was he using it yeah
he's using it okay I was able
to generate enough speed to do
it
it's like a elephant man yeah it's like a take on
Rhino I love this like melancholic Montage
of being a hero they they utilize their music
well like he's just doing his duty but
there's lack of emotion behind it yeah
the actions coupled with the song Make
Me Think like what he's doing right now
is like his pentant like he's like he
has to make up for all the damage he
caused yep yeah exactly yeah no I mean Mark's
traumatized of course yeah his dad is like a
monster a you don't have to go back if you're not
ready neither do you the amount of pain
that must be omitted from this these two
yeah see you later mom you too
what real EST day why don't you
move well kill the Iguana
do it already we've got security
turned up to 100 on YouTube new
cameras new guns new doors that won't
stop them you ain't gone nowhere yeah
they are immediately I [__] portals
now didn't I mention that see you around
Pete poor Pete probably so fright for his life
guys keep going in and out of Ja the hell are
we I bet he knows pepep sterling sterling knows
maybe they need the scientist mind of them what
happened here a tragedy this isn't your world my
name is angstrom ly that must be a big character
from the comics or something a Multiverse traveler
I imagine he would be working with the two of you
is a real ethical and moral stretch for me but
I don't have a choice there's no one else with
your scientific Gena I don't know there's
something that seems deceitful about you
man do they all know Mark
Grayson be friendly listen
I or cuz I think Nolan sorry your
dad got exploded yeah that's right
died right but I don't really want to
that sucks man totally sucks talk about
it I hear your dad was an okay guy though and he
was was like Jack right I bet you wish you got
those je and now he has to live alive during his
grief yeah but I don't get to be sad I'm part of
the problem I'm the reason all those people in
Chicago Died that's not true wait a second I I
shouldn't be here I should be out there classic
Hero's guilt you didn't kill those people Mark
omn man did but I didn't save them you stopped
your dad and saved the planet you didn't really
stop him you don't owe anyone anything that's
so sure I don't think Sten young gets enough
credit for how great of a voice job he does here
yeah man he's just a great overall actor I need
to be out there you need to start calling on
me again hold on I'm better I'm stronger I'm
ready no you're not could be worried about his
Darkness you think I haven't been watching your
early morning outings that's why I need you
it's only been a month Mark focus on your mom
your grades damn that passage of time is short
yeah the newscaster said it's only been a few
weeks in Chicago you saved a ton of them but you
also went through an emotional tumble dryer and
I need to know your head stop spinning before
I let you back in the game so no he can make a
callous decision I don't need your permission
to be a superhero you're not my dad you know
who else said that to me I'm not my dad that's
why omn man never joined I'm not my dad that's
that darkness that he's worried about you're not
my dad and I'm not my dad I mean what a tough
grieving position you feel like you got to take
some level of control this thing still going on
it's not going well hey it's Bobby the guardian
could use some help Invincible I'm not making
the same mistake I made with no one I thought he
died maybe he's a clone yeah om man killed him
what the hell he was a clone based on his speech
patterns in vocabulary the giant seems to have the
mental capacity of an 8-year-old an 8-year-old
what so is robot in the suit or is he piling
it remotely piling it remotely through his mind
maybe we can buy him some Comics or something a
damn I don't care how oh black Samson he needs to
go down now that's an excellent suggestion Samson
there's a multi-level parking garage beneath
this intersection I will detonate stress points
in the concrete and drop the giant into it I
love how they're working so much like a team
now come on why are you so me
me what happened I don't no I couldn't move
oh I guess he is Su in the suit my heart was
racing I was all sweaty that's fear before all
this was just a video game for you now you're
here in person playing for real oh [__] like
an armored suit situation yeah an Iron Man why
him discovering a new version of humanity I
would have just done neural link why not you
doing that before would just keep doing that
that's one of our sematic encoders but bigger
I based it off your design it reads copies
and writes human Minds design of our Earth
or their Earth what do you need it for what's
in it for us instead let me appeal to your
philanthropic nature go on I don't trust him
I don't trust him there's an infinite number
of dimensions and I was born with the ability
to access all of them why does he say in this
Dimension though remember that world changing
battle between omn man and Invincible a month
ago in most other dimensions they teamed up
and took over the planet oh all our problems
famine War climate change there's a solution out
there have been solved somewhere else and I can
be the conduit of that knowledge a Prometheus who
raises the bar for Everyone by sharing what works
he got a God complex a lot of power to do this
I need deep knowledge of those other dimensions
good thing we've always been inquisitive we've
always been so he is friends with them all that
meet the family wow he's self-absorbed he's
like a king he's like a king meets America
Chavez they don't have my ability but they have
something almost as valuable oh intimate local
knowledge of their home Dimensions that will
help me figure out what they do best and how
to get it here but you still want to be the
dominant one don't you of course help me do
this and I'll give you any single Dimension you
want as long as you promise not to hurt anyone
oh you are developing a villain we want one with
no superheroes good food and a population that
thinks we're Gods he's the one from the that we
were watching earlier who lost in the that one
we just cut to right there oh Eve got paralyzed
you were hurt as badly as I was both our husbands
died that night you can be sad and angry at the
same time that's grief for you Nolan killed so
many people he almost killed Mark 20 years and I
was a goddamn pet this feels so much more human I
like yeah like we can sit in the drama of it I
have to go back to Moscow in a few days but uh
what's this this something that helped me medical
marijuana it's good to see you mark uh I'm going
to go to my room Olam made dinner part8 just
the sadness permeates through all this I'm glad
they took this direction makes most sense last 15
engagements and narrowed it down to a failure of
leadership it was the prom last season I'm still
adjusting to my new body and I'm instituting a
change oh damn it's also obvious the team needs
more muscle meat bulletproof bulletproof hey oh
God damn re explode you think of that grade school
[__] yourself or did somebody help you with that
I I mean bulletproof isn't that great I know you
tyght be better I I was trying to be better was
new training schedules are in your lockers
first session is in 30 minutes dismissed I
can't quite pinpoint the animation but there's
just something that feels more refined about it
my leadership has been suboptimal and that's
a problem and like any problem it needs to be
fixed there are Great Character setups here
they're also a natural continuation of last
season when I was a kid I always wanted to be my
dad what if that happens what if I become him and
I don't even know it that is the horror you have
to face it's a real fear yeah you're not your dad
Mark the whole world knows that Cecil doesn't
so prove him wrong there's more detail to the
facial expressions too there's a lot I like
a more about the way it looks Mark it's not
a good I'll work for you I'll follow orders I'll
let you make all the calls put me back out there
energy levels just went off the chart I wonder
how that'll work out for Mark someone get this
kid an earpiece what happens when Mark doesn't
like the order that's an inevitable problem we'll
probably face also Mark has to find out that
most of the other versions of him joined his
dad yeah it's really going to mess with them open
your portals and we'll connect to the other nine
machines transdimensional interconnects
are stable 1,000 Minds synchronized how
can your brain handle then once we start
the process it's impossible to stop at
these power levels severe brain damage
would be the the least of your problems
oh yeah that's probably going to push him
over the edge getting all that information
overload I am large I contain multitude
oh my God that's not good spit it out
kid okay there's like a giant mechanical
Christmas tree with like a bunch of the same
guys ah wait Invincible you don't understand he's
definitely not Invincible stop this is for
the greater good that's what all villains
say oh all the M twins you
were using other uses you
said we were [Music] special that's what they all
say
this is the first time Invincible ever encountered
them huh I was just thinking that yeah yes
woof stop him but don't kill
him oh we're going to do
both get up man oh I was going to use that
Rage that's enough I said stop Vite rage
we're almost done why doesn't he want
Invincible that they might maybe he is
good I don't know I won't build my Utopia
with blood oh he has ethics I was going to
take it off going to mess him up is good maybe
taking it off too early is going to mess him
up that's I thought God damn killed the mullers
killed all of them at least a fraction of them
what I did not call it I thought he was going to
go down a really I thought he was for sure bad I
think he still could be sure he said he would
have build it a with blood man like he refused
to let Invincible die in that moment just cuz
he's has a code of ethics doesn't mean he's
not bad no no no not again uh the guilt look I I
don't know what they were up to but I'd say you
stopped it pretty in spectacularly and even the
MERS didn't deserve this everyone here did this
to themselves and whatever they were planning you
stopped them man this is so tragic like there's
never a real victory for him anymore some male
came for you you first get into college no way
you first okay same time what is this no way
home on being accepted to Upstate University
Miss Bennett what do you wanted to say say that
we're going to college together I don't believe
you quit being a [__] [Music] Amber I believe
you now oh my God I got in I got in hey yay
he doesn't trust him I don't know if you
heard but I'm working for Cecil now so
you know if you needs some help or want
to team up just give me a Cecil thinks
you're on our side yeah I'm not so sure
Mark needs to be sure to I'll be watching
you oh man what an episode one wow oh oh
I forgot about that I forgot they do that
the one from the other Universe probably
survived the one with the the sweatshirt
we saw I told him not to take off the damn
helmet oh oh God oh God brother is that
you what the hell how are you even [Music]
breathing oh no oh it's the one he had the
superb brain the no what did he do to me oh [__]
oh wow he did this it made me a freak I ruined
everything he's going to be a villain yeah you've
lost track of what memories are yours and which
come from the others they are all my memories
you need a hospital what the hell is a hospital
going to do I need Revenge I need need to make
him pay I won't rest until I've G there it is a
h [Music] oh oh oh I guess we're going to build to
the cracks now oh another one it's the last time I
work for anyone else ever it's not wow wow what
a great episode one it is yeah he's like um The
Who's The Incredible Hulk villain oh the leader
the leader yeah he's like the leader yeah yeah
like a multiversal leader wow man that was a good
episode they they looked sharp I feel like their
clothes looked especially sharp this time around
the details on it yeah it's fresher in your AR I'm
seg Wang reject Nation shop.com baby that's what
I'm talking about guys I want to thank everyone
who's been buying shirts over at the real reject
store we got shirts like this one child protection
services here crossover between Pedro Pascal
lass us and of course grou from Mandalorian
show we also got other ones like space babies of
the Galaxy we got who influences the influencers
is Watchman inspired we also got the America's
ass one as well that's my new personal favorite
one love that one we got our soda shirt we got
our snip shirt we got the bat verse t-shirt we
got a whole bunch of other te's over there and I
really appreciate cuz we are creatively involved
with all them it's been uh remarkable to see the
level of support it's it's honestly my favorite
way that people have been supporting the channel
simply because like yeah we get to get involved
creatively with it I love seeing people rocking
them and wearing them and if you end up buying one
tag us on social media and we'll be sure to add
share a story of it and all that jazz because we
absolutely appreciate it and love it and I love to
see when people are rocking them as well any let's
talk about this episode of invincible my friend
yeah we just saw a villain origin story right
now have me going man it was real back and forth
I mean for the most part I was like gangho he's a
villainous and then he made a um the Evelyn Choice
there in the end he's like I will not have this
built on blood and then it lands him in the blame
territory yeah just killed a lot of people when
it's like dude you made your choice yeah he's got
his head scrambled because he was the one who made
the choice he was the one who said like I will not
like they could have let him kill Invincible yeah
he's for him to blame he's like no man you got all
wrong but it's all mixed up because maybe there
were other ones who were thinking Invincible
die I figured as soon as he put that helmet
on he's going to download all of them like okay
yeah he's definitely going to be bad after this
but there's everyone with like different thoughts
and choices too who would have probably preferred
that Invincible died yeah cuz most universes He's
the bad guy with exactly exactly but this guy knew
that this invincible was good oh man so yeah he's
that's clever yeah this multiversal threat that
now has essentially like schizophrenia that's wild
that's wild that's insane what I love about what
what the show Invincible does it takes a lot of
these whereas like the boys is very much like
satirical and commentary on superhero universes
like Invincible still lives and breeds the comic
book world and the tropes but makes it their own
yeah and does it in a way that's much more mature
and R-rated with a little bit of commentary here
or there of course um but they you take it serious
you know yeah and I think that's what they've done
here too is like we've seen so much Multiverse
stuff and now we're going to get like the R-rated
version of a Multiverse in the comic book medium
which I'm really excited about yeah yeah I think
this show does what I like about comic books in
the sense that it is this larger than life kind of
U experience but they do have a lot of character
depth within their storytelling and I feel like
within most of the modern or more mainstream comic
book properties we really just to barely scratch
the surface of what that means and like those
those deeper character themes and I like the fact
that we're the show allows us to sit with those
things allows us to explore what what it means to
be a superhero what what it means to live within
that World um rather than trying to you know get
to the plot and like kind of like okay we got to
we got to get through this we we got six episodes
or like oh we only got two hours uh no let's just
actually live with those characters you know
kind of uh yeah explores in a meaningful way
which I appreciate and yeah no I I kind of I kind
of agree with everything you're saying we're kind
of commenting throughout the whole episode
the fact that this really is an exploration
of where do we go next with Mark where do we go
next with this world how is the world receiving
what happened and how is Mark taking that on and
I think it's it's a very smart and interesting
choice the fact that he internally wrestles
with who he is and his identity and trying to
prove that he's not the bad guy even though the
world and certain people within his life may see
him as such and like the guilt that comes with
that and like it's that classic superhero Thing
of the weight of the world on your shoulders but
tackled in a more meaningful way which I really
appreciated very meaningful it because so much of
like last season when Mark uh you know dealt with
him being told that this is his Destiny you
know he would wait around for when his powers
are going to kick in because he's a vulture might
he's not just human and then after become vulture
might his whole identity was as reestablished here
he his whole goal was to become his dad at least
the image of what his dad fostered here on this
planet like I want to become the Savior worshiped
him and then a month ago that's all shattered now
yeah and I love what I love that they're doing is
they're leading with the Doom and Gloom like the
the Doom and Gloom looms over everything here CU
it extends far beyond just Mark and his mom it's
the the world this was the world Superman this
was the world savior yeah and the world savior is
actually the world's greatest enemy now and their
their biggest threat like it's it was the biggest
Con in the world and you feel like nothing is as
safe as it once was then you have Mark who is
still amateur uh hero there's he's nowhere near
the professional grade hero that he needs to be
at and the threatening part of it is it makes
him susceptible to give into the darkness not not
that I ever think arm mark would ever give into
the darkness uh but I like that they set up that
in other worlds he he does give into it that most
worlds he does succumb to thinking this is the
right way and I love the portrayal of that because
the portrayal he do he genuinely is like it's such
a Draconian evil way of thinking of he's not just
like spouting mean lines he's constantly like well
you did this to yourself yeah you're the reason
you're about to die like you made this choice and
you're not thinking about what's actually really
good so I have to annihilate you it's Sinister and
in a way where there's no awareness of just the
the the amount of Cruelty you know know it is it
is pure evil dominance and Mark being in the being
thrusted in with a different kind of Darkness
from feeling betrayed by his dad I love that cil's
because last season ceso wanted him to work with
him and then to pick it up here is actually a more
human choice of being like you're kind of in too
dark of a place and that leaves you in a way to
be influenced by Darkness a lot worse so I'm going
to I I kind of need to keep you at a distance or I
need to keep you under control which is the only
way Cecil would have let him work for him is if
Cil can control him in some way right you know
um and not let him just be his own free agent as
well yeah they got like a lot of Great Character
setup too which is really compelling and a lot of
complexity to it yeah I like the mom is having
a more prominent role in it as well because we
get to see her side of things with her uh meeting
with her friend and like us allowing us to to sit
in that moment with her and to see where where her
story is going to go you know cuz she had it was
just as big of a loss for her as it was for Mark
like that was her husband of 20 years and knowing
someone for 20 years and finding out they viewed
you as a pet not only they viewed you as a pet but
they're this supremely evil being that wants to
destroy and take over the planet like man that's
that's that's a lot you know and I hope we get
to a point where we get to see both Mark and her
kind of come together because yeah grief can be a
a very isolating experience you know like they're
both trying to even though they both know the
other isn't okay they're both trying to like keep
it all together well they have a shared trauma
bond in a way you know they have a shared tragedy
together son betrayed by a father and that father
is the Betrayed the wife yeah H so there is there
they them two only have each other and they're the
only ones who can sort of understand and the mom
has to constantly um put up the this appearance
of strength and and capability you know so I think
there's a lot of and there's other characters we
haven't checked in with like art and whatever I
like the development of um of our team like what
they set up with robot I think is great uh of him
having to better understand because it was a human
controlling the robot machine and now he is he has
been reborn essentially and now he's having to
understand fear in a different way like and how
to make choices like that as well which I think is
really compelling stuff because in the last season
when he when he did get the body he did just keep
it neurally linked with stuff so I I just assume
that's what he would do again so I'm I'm curious
what the choice is to actually be in the suit it
feels so much more dangerous yeah so um but there
must be a reasoning to at the same time it's going
to allow him to develop more as a human human and
even as whatever that little like overgrown fetus
looking thing that he was before that he still
was like artificial in a way yeah you know and
and now he's going to really find his Humanity I
think like they've they've really set up a good
human development with him even Rex Spode seems a
little more human than before like he's not still
douchy but not as douchy yeah cuz he was cheating
on uh Kate the first season right right just all
ego and uh he's been a humbled yeah yeah I'm
curious to see where the other characters go
like we watched a whole special with Alice Eve
we really to spend a lot of time with her this
episode Adam Adam Eve what did I say Alice Eve yep
that's that actress but yeah Adam Eve I think that
uh yeah I'm curious to see where her head is at
you know CU we only got really that one scene with
her and Mark uh towards like the the middle-ish
end we didn't even check in with Mark's friend
yeah yeah we didn't no this this is William his
name yeah William I think so yeah there's a yeah
this show has a big cast and obviously invincible
and marker the lead of that show and of this cast
but yeah I think the the show's done a great job
of of having a great Ensemble of of interesting
fleshed out well well-written characters and
yeah just makes you curious to see where all
these things go because this is kind of as you
said before the uh natural continuation of this
journey that we've kind of started with the first
season and yeah I think there's I don't know there
a lot of potential for a really interesting story
to uh to come out of that I'm pretty sure that
they kept us really focused yeah and Mel and kept
molic yeah because they could have cut around to
like every character and they just cut they didn't
cut around to a lot of other characters they
kept it really focused on the on the soul of this
story yeah CU what happened was really heavy yeah
and there's like nothing but Darkness for Mark
like like everything kind of just feels like a
loss in some way mhm you know H even when he has a
victory it doesn't really truly feel like nothing
truly feels Victorious for the guy uh I think it's
great I thought I thought this was a really solid
P like I know like the last couple of episodes
of season 1 were super exciting and super intense
and maybe they thought they we go like full steam
ahead um but I really like this direction of the
first episode a lot yeah we needed to come back
down because you know we had this extreme high
and now we're in the the aftermath of that like
it's only been a few weeks to a month within its
world so we need to see like where everybody's
at you know it's primarily mark my my question
as of right now obviously we're going to continue
watching so we find out what happens but wasn't
was that a post credit scene the fact that um
Seth Rogan's character said like we need to
start preparing because the VMS are coming yeah
yeah no that what uh that was the ending or the
post credit I forget which one of of last season
but like is that information or that something
that's happened as of yet because I think at the
end of that's definitely happened yeah did they
I don't they referenced it in the episod they
did not reference it in this episode um which
oh you're saying like maybe that was a scene that
happens later on in the story we're going to find
out that some of this is actually happening before
the interaction exactly maybe perhaps um I don't
think so CU I feel like that's like an immediate
threat like oh yeah that's that's what I mean is
what I thought we were going to go like pedal
to the metal we need to like get our alliance
ready for when omn man returns exactly U or the
vulture mites return because they're going to try
to dominate so that's why I think the Multiverse
thing is is a fascinating fascinating thing to
infuse in here because there's like a couple
of ways you can go about it you can have um
you can form a greater Alliance to protect your
Earth whatever our Earth is called or you can
make the Threat Level worse because you got other
invincibles and omn man out there you know so I
I don't know which area it's going to go down but
I I really feel like we haven't seen anything yet
oh no yeah cuz we just started this plot with the
the Multiverse and our new seemingly antagonist
and but I want to just get back to omn man you
know I don't really I like I like the setup of
what the door it's opening but I'm like ah just
get back on yeah I mean I'm it definitely has me
curious for sure like how this is going to
connect to the other stuff and I wonder if
we're going to put the omn man stuff on the back
burner to address this multiversal thing right
now or if these are going to these two things
are going to correlate and uh come together to
kind of stop this this end or like this uh threat
that's coming sure yeah I get what you're saying
I get what you're getting um but yeah overall
um really loved it uh a lot uh different than I
expected it to be but I did appreciate the focus
of it a lot I thought that was great I thought
that was really great seriously yeah um what did
you guys think did you like the first episode
leave your thoughts down below thank you guys for
joining us uh you can be sure to subscribe leave
a like click that Bell All That Jazz and uh we'll
catch you all soon peace out reack Nation [Music]